oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
bish
[Music]
of bathrooms
ten times fifteen times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten
[Music]
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dump dumps
big massive dumpster
[Music]
that it was massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
dumps
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
old water because pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a night at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
that is telling my children who not to
be it's happening
[Music]
a
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you
[Music]
mangoes my bad the mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and
99 seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes manga aren't mangoes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
[Music]
bring my mango
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy
to be healthy
[Music]
well welcome everybody we have major
breaking news today we have finally
figured out the third element of the
bathroom you've got your sink
you've got your shower
and then there's that third element and
we have figured out finally
exactly what it is no uh we have an
emergency last minute january sixth
committee hearing starting in mere
moments
the expectation is that the former aide
to white house chief of staff mark
meadows is going to testify she's got
the goods she's the one who uh i believe
if i wrote actually let's just look at
it i have an article instead of me just
making stuff up which is most of the
show is me making stuff up
let's look at something meadow's aid
will testify beautiful
cassidy hutchinson aid to mark meadows
witness to many critical events and
conversations is expected to testify
today
she's already been interviewed video
clips have been featured her life
testimony would be a significant moment
as she has long been considered one of
the most consequent consequential
witnesses due to the proximity to former
president donald trump's then white
house chief of staff
she is presumably
going to make headlines in this hearing
let's not even guess about what it is
other than other than
to remember
that she is aware of people who were
asking for pardons
she is aware of so many different things
so many different things
um and we are going to hear from her in
20 minutes so this is an absolutely
explosive day i'm so glad to have people
here with us today
and i anticipate many important elements
to be presented at the hearings let me
make sure i don't fall behind on
thanking so many great people including
people re-upping twitch prime
subscriptions hersafat
disc golf brain matter multi beast jay
tandaway just gifted five
glitteriest lady dread
marjorie
my bag of mangoes silky girl jen here
dirt knapp billy carpenter jen here
again
as well as weather boxer shot x thomas
jen here
that puts us at 16.
wow just to kick things off and also
really appreciate everybody signing up
on my website including ashley flooring
as well as angelica pilger angelica
gifting a subscription putting us at 18.
it is not clear how long today's
hearings will go but we will be here and
we will be watching
that's what it is
a thanks to polo dal as well for the
twitch prime subscription let me know
via super chat how consequential do you
expect today's last minute hearing to be
i believe it will be
oh hold on here's the moment about the
the party mr brooks
i know
both advocated for
there'd be a blanket pardon four members
involved in that meeting and a handful
of other members that weren't at
december 21st meaning
as the pre-emptive part is
mr gates was personally pushing for a
pardon that was the big blockbuster
which we covered yesterday for some
reason that is unclear to us gates was
desperate for a pardon
before the trump riots which makes us
wonder what what would have made him
want the pardon so early on
thanks savvy lemons for the twitch prime
subscription ben hubert says david
really glad you're back sir
i hope you the baby and especially your
girlfriend and fiance are doing well my
girlfriend's doing really well my fiance
is recovering currently so you know
everybody different different status for
everybody
that's a joke by the way she can
corroborate big massive dumps at the
white house and toilets flushing 10
times 15 times with incriminating
evidence against trump well said
well said
thanks to andrew kravetsky who just
signed up at joinpakman.com today's
coupon code folks is indict now
do i have to explain today's coupon code
i hope that i don't
is indict a clear enough coupon code
that we can skip the explanation like
with obama obama i would explain and i
would go well this is the this is the
source of obama it doesn't win your
secular members gonna be in trouble big
trouble remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama yeah there you go so that one i
explained so people understand it but i
feel like indict is just so obvious in
its meaning i don't think i need an
explanation for that
let's look at a couple different things
as we stand by here
um there was there's bit now you might
be saying like david this must be months
old no yesterday there was another
arizona forensic audit presentation
and
election fraud conspiracy theorist jovan
pulitzer says there is no cue
when the conspiracy theorists are not on
the same page i love it you don't
address it nothing's going to stop it
what is going to stop it this room there
is no cue
i'm sorry folks
it's just a way to make you stand down
and not do anything and get yourself on
a list nobody's coming to save you
except you that's right there's no
military coming to save you except you
be right
so anyway this is like when flat
earthers are like oh well no it's
obvious that the earth is flat because
the nasa pictures are composites and uh
i've never fallen off and then someone
else goes no actually the earth is flat
you know and then they argue with each
other like they agree the earth is flat
but for reasons that couldn't possibly
both be true
um yes i'm covering the carrie lake drag
queens fiasco
on today's podcast that is absolutely
happening
am i a fan of uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos no but i do love
myself a good calzone by the way how are
the calzones yeah
now that we're up under of elito's
regime we're looking very strongly at
forming a new pack for progressive
candidates in the next few weeks all
right very exciting news haley thank you
and now she can corroborate what a
grudge ridden ron johnson claims plus
g lane maxwell getting sentenced today
as well what a day oh when is the gilain
maxwell sentencing
that sounds like an interesting thing to
cover as well
jilane maxwell oh hold on is it
happening right now
sentencing
wow
it appears that the sentencing is
imminent so we're going to have to cover
that as well
wow okay
big big big news day that's absolutely
for sure so we'll we'll try to cover all
of it
other super chats coming in do you think
other rights such as gay marriage are in
danger and if so what does that mean for
those currently married yeah i've
already said it uh i've been saying it
for months now clarence thomas actually
wrote it now all of a sudden everybody
believes me of course
of course they're coming for more
sir your girlfriend is okay with telling
us elements of her medical or is she up
in the air wanted to make sure she's
okay with it yeah no elements of medical
are a big thing elements of medical yep
that's a big deal
when can we expect another stephen
kenneth destiny the second always a fan
of your collabs love you're covering
this glad girlfriend's recovering take
care david much love yeah i'm willing to
talk to stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
ii
anytime anytime he wants
obama has gotten me through some hard
days it never gets old obama i know
love the show pacman sir can you give a
shout out to my boys eric and roland who
are also watching your stream absolutely
scott eric and roland welcome
globalished no no no no that's a little
bit below the belt
we're not going globalist on them
thanks to radicopter montellius and nzn8
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 24 today
also want to say thanks to alexander
gutsy for the twitch for the website
subscription and jody bundrick gifting
one that's numbers 25 and 26. folks we
have a coupon code it's barely legal
only because the january 6th committee
is tied up with more important things is
this code indict
going under the radar
otherwise it would be done so how long
until interracial marriage becomes a
political issue again yeah i think
interracial marriage is pretty far down
the line but a federal ban on abortion
is something they would love uh
undoing gay marriage is something that
they would love there's a lot of
different things here that they would
love to hit
all right so we did this here's rudy
giuliani rudy giuliani was tapped on the
back at a shoprite
and rudy is claiming basically that he
was almost murdered
it's pretty wild check this out this was
rudy uh speaking
out on the street somewhere yeah he hit
me hard enough to knock me forward about
like
now
i'm 78 years old
[Music]
you know elderly people die mostly from
falls
this guy could kill me
if i were if i were a weak 78 year old i
might not be here today right
and here is so
the entire story is so implausible that
even newsmax host greg kelly is like
rudy i've seen the video quite frankly
it really didn't seem that bad this is
the when even newsmax is telling you
it's not making a lot of sense
you got to reconsider your position take
a look at this
i didn't know it was this good i really
didn't and his
his grasp of the issues
particularly the issue of pride in the
economy
and by the way it sounds like some kind
of uh uh vehicle backfiring uh alongside
the interview
and the main thing that he has is
passion
tremendous
hey mr mayor is somebody mowing the lawn
right outside your window i can barely
hear you yeah yeah we're we're at a big
rally we're at a big rally in staten
island
right around the corner from where i was
attacked yesterday
we have that actually you were at a i
guess a delicate testament of some kind
i'm gonna show the people what happened
and you tell me because let me see the
video if you don't mind uh
this person with the hand on your back
i gotta be honest it doesn't look that
bad but
oh god i i understand that looks can be
deceiving
you know that that was
that was the woman who was rubbing my
back not the guy who lived
but you're watching
so the woman that woman uh
gave a statement to the police the car
continues to backfire outside the i mean
everything going wrong here
the guy hit me so hard that she herself
almost fell right from the reverberation
of it
it was it echoed throughout the building
i want to see it again
so rudy's claim is that this woman right
here almost fell
he was hit so hard this woman almost
fell let's see if that's true
and you tell me because let me see the
video if you don't mind uh
this person she did not almost fall
with the hand on your back
i gotta be honest it doesn't look that
bad but i i understand that looks can be
deceiving
you know that that was
that was the woman who was rubbing my
back not the guy who hit me but you're
watching
so the woman that woman uh
gave a statement to the police that the
guy hit me so hard that she herself
almost fell she was almost down on the
ground from the reverberation of it
she's a city worker
there's a second grade detective
that that's that's the lady who uh
helped me all right good that makes
sense
yeah greg kelly's been convinced by that
man what an insane situation we have in
this country today
wow
oh man i'm gonna need a moment just to
even recover from that that's that's
something else
thanks to kyle court for signing up at
joinpacman.com and corey schutz for
gifting a subscription folks today is a
perfect day to sign up on my website
okay listen quite frankly
this we are primarily a community funded
show
okay as liz cheney enters the chamber
uh and adam kinzinger and everybody
ready to discharge their duty here as
members of the committee
joinpacman.com is the place to sign up
we have a coupon code the code is indict
you understand what it is
okay
it's obama gate the greatest crime of
the century no
it's just memberships okay um indict is
the coupon code and i will thank
everybody thanks also to people signing
up on twitch cameratagius
mizunlikelygamer
anir banbagchi
con queso that means with cheese in my
native spanish that puts us at 32
32.
welcome everybody you've missed nothing
yet it's starting at the top of the hour
sir are we going to find out you sought
a pardon for illegal discounts yeah i
wanted a blanket pardon
exactly
should have pushed him into the sea no i
don't advocate for violence rudy should
be investigated he should be charged if
he committed
elements of medical or elements of
criminality
or elements of bathrooms charge them for
all of it but no i don't i don't support
physical violence that's not that's not
my gig
so we're going to keep that off the uh
off the screen
i don't like it folks
okay and i think i had maybe one other
thing
oh here's just another weird moment at
another rudy event let's check this out
you gotta hold the bottom okay
well you don't have to hold it for me
because
it helps i'm a little embarrassed about
that
i hold anything for you
if we were in manhattan that would get
us votes
oh my god
some kind of thank you trump event a
very very strange event needless to say
uh oh boy
very bizarre
voicemails calling it calling coming in
people with a number of different
messages
let's see if i have anything relevant to
this hearing for you guys
not offhand
sir do you think mccarthy rejected a
bipartisan select committee to make
trump look
we know that he doesn't like trump seems
reasonable to me to make trump look what
bad good
i think we're missing a critical word
there
rumor has it that there was an
earthquake felt in los angeles as a
result of the person who slapped rudy on
the back
five dollars for a small bag of carrots
to feed your family i'm big on carrots i
will uh i will actually grate carrots
directly into a salad i've been known to
do it and not everybody agrees with it
but i think it's a beautiful move you
don't see that at restaurants often i
think it's a great touch
just great carrots directly onto the
salad
gross what
who's it people don't like who people
don't like carrots i've never even heard
of that
yeah no it's bizarre
the concept of people not liking carrots
well listen
to each their own david happy belated
father's day curious about your thoughts
on bill maher's descent into neolib
libertarian madness honestly i haven't
seen any bill maher stuff in so long i
don't even know what's going on with him
um which indictment for trump is likely
from merrick garland manhattan or
georgia if i if you said you i just have
to pick one
i think the georgia indictment is the
most likely trump indictment what do you
guys think in the chat let me know i
think that that one is by far the most
likely
yep people
i guess agree i don't know
people are furious okay fine people can
be furious that's fine you're allowed
it's not a big deal
thanks to c missile and koyani
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 33
and 34.
today's coupon code is indict
if you prefer to use the code obama you
still can obama but the coupon code
today is indict
i did have a dave ramsey element that i
wanted to look at
where
uh he says crazy stuff i just don't know
how much time it looks like they're
about to start let's hold off on that
we'll look at that a little bit later
yeah
um
is this reporter like in a train
bathroom very strange location and we
are also standing by for the gilain
maxwell sentencing
very very big
um
perpetration of justice some would call
it
super chat's coming in do you think any
past trump voters would have support
changed by the january 6 committee some
i don't think many
but some
between the attack on rudy and the
vicious elbow thrown by nancy pelosi how
concerned are you with the violence the
left has engaged in recently yeah very
nicely done daniel i like that
make him him look bad is mccart did
mccarthy oppose a bipartisan hearing
in order to make trump look bad
i i it's so hard to say it's so hard to
say i understand the origins of the
question
but yeah
do i ever put radishes on salad
absolutely
absolutely i grew my own radishes sliced
them up it's a beautiful thing
i want to say thanks to justin mckinley
excuse me need a sip of water
thank you justin mckinley just signed up
at joinpackman.com and his new num
member number 35 today justin i really
appreciate that
i invite you
yes you to sign up at joinpacman.com
get a membership today's coupon code
is indict
service which vegetable do you think
trump likes the best you know people who
don't really like vegetables
usually they're like i like potatoes and
what they mean is they like french fries
trump strikes me as like that type of
guy right i mean i don't see trump
being prep you know
favorable towards broccolini a beautiful
vegetable uh
trump doesn't strike me like as a swiss
chard type of guy
tomato sauce yeah i know that's another
one isn't that like a reagan thing where
it was like either tomato sauce or
ketchup that counted as a vegetable in
school lunch
yeah trump seems like the type of guy
who would say his favorite vegetables
are either french fries
or tomato sauce on pizza
no i'm not vegetarian
the rest of the world is deeply
concerned for america i speak on behalf
of the world indeed indeed
check out daily show's jordan clepper
showing january 6 footage to maga people
at trump rallies that sounds interesting
let me i'll look for that during the
hearing
thanks to aaron nappy bernie on a boat
as well as bose staff and brains for the
twitch prime subscriptions that drops us
into 38
an extraordinary number
you said origin but i think you meant
oranges you don't have the best words
david people tell me nobody used oranges
before i did do i have out here
let me see take a look at the oranges of
the investigation exactly
we will do it
do you think the outcome of the
committee will reflect much in europe no
i do not
uh let's see if i can find the clepper
video
clepper
riot i don't even know how to search for
it let's see
[Music]
jordan clepper
oh here it is okay let's check this out
a little bit okay
if the hearing starts let me know
[Applause]
[Music]
last weekend the trump freedom tour
comprised of don his son and a caravan
of folks looking for book deals headed
to mississippi and i was curious who was
shelling out the nine to four thousand
dollars for a ticket to see the show
much of the country was watching the
revelations coming out of the january
6th hearings and surely these
politically engaged folks were also
tuned in have you guys been watching the
january 6th hearings um
no have you watched any of the january 6
hearings not really i had it bore up and
changing phones
but uh good to what
i changed phones are you watching them
no
no why not well anytime you don't have
time to watch a two-hour
hearing yeah not at all how long are you
here today until five until five which
is you got here at i got here at seven
seven which makes it ten hours right
with the two hour hearing who's got time
for that [ __ ] most were paying no
attention and yet there were some paying
even less attention what about what
happened on january 6th what do you
think what happened there
i don't really know what happened on
january 6th oh boy january 6th
the election day
no election day was back in november do
you
i don't even know what do you know about
january 6th no so when i say january 6
that means nothing i don't know that's
just a day to you yeah
did you hear about the the insurrection
attempt at the capitol
no no for almost everyone here
insurrectioning was a non-issue it was
the hearings themselves that were the
problem i think it's an abomination it's
just mccarthyism it's a witch trial it's
a witch-hunt uh it is yeah it's like a
mob of people coming together with
pitchforks yeah saying and we can't have
that yeah with a with an agenda here's
the narrative we're pushing and that's
all we're pushing
a mob of people with an agenda
pushing an agenda that can't stand in
america no we should we should have an
investigation about a mob of people
that's something everybody would watch
that investigate the hearings there's an
idea
oh nancy pelosi she start is very
responsible for what went on then she
planned it she she planned what happened
i believe so why did she plan to get
attacked by a mob of trump supporters
because she wanted to be able to blame
it on the trump supporters and have
something bad to say about him shouldn't
we investigate that uh yes so you must
be watching the january 6 committee
no
so what was it people were watching wow
this is very depressing 1000 mules came
out and you showed a lot of stuff uh
you've got 2 000 mules and then this
movie i'm 2 000 mules 2 000 mules yes
two thousand mules is a documentary by
dinesh d'souza claiming massive voter
fraud based on some cell phone data and
surveillance footage that's been lauded
by trump laughed at by bill barr
discredited by fact checkers and banned
from even right wow all right well i
encourage people to check that out i
don't want to play the entire thing
um
that that is extraordinarily depressing
wow
wow
okay we are moments away from the start
of today's hearings and that's a really
great thing because i'm as curious as
all of you to hear uh about what uh ms
hutchinson is going to be saying i want
to say thank you to lee lee mw tron
paperwings try gamer
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 42
huge thank you i want to applaud two
great americans i actually don't even
know if they're american it doesn't
matter but that's okay
uh tara vega just signed up on my
website joinedpakman.com and zack james
just signed up on my website
joinedpacman.com those are new
subscribers numbers 43 and 44 today
folks if you're just joining us we are
back
uh here is the witness and it is indeed
miss hutchinson this is going to be
explosive
you can use the coupon code indict
to sign up at joinpakman.com that is the
place to support our program the streams
will continue the podcast will continue
this hearing is going to be something
else i believe and we are moments away
moments away from the start
uh reached out for pardons after the
sixth she was also reportedly the source
who okay
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material presented
during this hearing
good afternoon
in our hearings over the previous weeks
the select committee has laid out the
details of a multi-part pressure
campaign
driven by the former president aimed at
overturning the results of the 2020
presidential election
and blocking the transfer of power
we've shown that this effort was based
on a lie
a lie that the election was stolen
tainted by widespread fraud
donald trump's big lie
in the weeks ahead the committee will
hold additional hearings about how
donald trump
summoned a mob of his supporters to
washington
spurred them to march on the capitol and
failed to take meaningful action to
quell the violence as it was unfolding
on january 6th
however
in recent days the select committee has
obtained new information
dealing with what was going on in the
white house on january 6th and in the
days prior oh this is going to be good
specific detailed information about
what the former president and his top
aides were doing and saying
in those critical hours
firsthand details of what transpired in
the office of the white house chief of
staff
just steps from the oval office
as the threats of violence became clear
and indeed violence ultimately descended
on the capitol
in the attack on american democracy
it's an important it's important that
the american people hear that
information immediately
that's why in consultation with the vice
chair
i've recalled the committee for today's
hearing
as you've seen and heard in our earlier
hearings the select committee has
developed a massive body of evidence
thanks to the many hundreds of witnesses
who have voluntarily provided
information relevant to our
investigation
it hasn't always been easy to get that
information
because the same people who drove the
former president's pressure campaign
to overturn the election are now trying
to cover up the truth about january 6th
but thanks to the courage of certain
individuals the truth won't be buried
the american people won't be left in the
dark
our witness today ms cassidy hutchinson
has embodied that courage
i won't get into a lot of detail about
miss hutchinson's testimony we'll show
i'll allow her words to speak for
themselves and i hope everyone at home
will listen very closely
first i recognize our distinguished vice
chair ms cheney of wyoming for any
opening statement she'd care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
in our first five hearings the committee
has heard from a significant number of
republicans including former trump
administration justice department
officials trump campaign officials
several members of president trump's
white house staff a prominent
conservative judge and several others
today's witness ms cassidy hutchinson is
another republican and another former
member of president trump's white house
staff
certain of us in the house of
representatives
recall that ms hutchinson once worked
for house republican whip steve scalise
but she is also a familiar face on
capitol hill
because she held a prominent role in the
white house legislative affairs office
and later was the principal aide to
president trump's chief of staff mark
meadows
ms hutchinson has spent considerable
time up here on capitol hill
representing the trump administration
and we welcome her back
up until now our hearings have each been
organized to address specific elements
of president trump's plan to overturn
the 2020 election
today we are departing somewhat from
that model because ms hutchinson's
testimony touches on several important
and cross-cutting topics
topics that are relevant to each of our
future hearings
in her role working for the white house
chief of staff
ms hutchinson handled a vast number of
sensitive issues she worked in the west
wing several steps down the hall from
the oval office
ms hutchinson spoke daily with members
of congress with high-ranking officials
in the administration with senior white
house staff including mr meadows
with white house counsel lawyers and
with mr tony ornato who served as the
white house deputy chief of staff
she also worked on a daily basis with
members of the secret service who were
posted in the white house
in short ms hutchinson was in a position
to know a great deal about the
happenings in the trump white house
miss hutchinson has already sat for four
videotaped interviews with committee
investigators and we thank her very much
for her cooperation and for her courage
we will cover certain but not all
relevant topics within ms hutchinson's
knowledge today
again our future hearings will supply
greater detail putting the testimony
today in a broader and more complete
context
today you will hear ms hutchinson relate
certain first-hand observations of
president trump's conduct on january 6th
you will also hear new information
regarding the actions and statements of
mr trump's senior advisors that day
including his chief of staff mark
meadows and his white house counsel
and we will begin to examine evidence
bearing on what president trump and
members of the white house staff knew
about the prospect for violence on
january 6 even before that violence
began
to best communicate the information the
committee has gathered we will follow
the practice of our recent hearings
playing videotape testimony from miss
hutchinson and others and also posing
questions to miss hutchinson live
mr chairman i yield back wow
thank you very much our witness today is
miss cassie hutchinson who served in the
trump administration in the white house
office of legislative affairs from 2019
to 2020 and as a special assistant to
the president in the white house chief
of staff's office
from march 2020 through january 2021
i will now swear in our witness the
witness will please stand and raise her
right hand
you swear a
on the penalty of perjury that the
testimony you're about to give is the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated
how soon does trump post the truth about
her as a record reflect the witness
answered in the affirmative
i now recognize
myself for questions
ms hutchinson i'd like to start with a
few questions about your background
the these are some photographs we've
obtained highlighting your career
these show
you with members of congress including
steve
scalise
as well as the white house was leader
kevin mccarthy and jim jordan
others show you with the president
and members of congress aboard air force
one
before you worked in the white house
you worked on capitol hill for
representative steve scalise the
republican whip and senator ted cruz
and then in 2019 you moved to the white
house and served there until the end of
the trump administration
in 2020
when you started at the white house you
served at in the office of legislative
affairs we understand that you were
initially hired as a staff assistant
but was soon promoted to a position of
greater responsibility
can you explain your role for the
committee
when i moved over to the white house
chief of staff's office with mr meadows
when he became the fourth chief of staff
it's difficult to describe a typical day
i was a special assistant to the
president and an advisor advisor to the
chief of staff
the days depended on what the president
was doing that day and that's kind of
how my portfolio was reflected i had a
lot of outreach with members of congress
senior cabinet cabinet officials
we would work i would work on policy
issues with relevant internal components
and members on the hill
as well as security protocol at the
white house complex for mr meadows and
the president
and then you were
you received another promotion in march
2020
at that time you became the principal
aide
to the new white house chief of staff
mark meadows is that right that's
correct sir
what did a typical day look like for you
in your work with mr meadows
it varied with what was going on we
spent a lot of time on the hill i spent
time on the hill independently too as i
was his liaison for capitol hill
um
we did a lot of presidential travel
engagements but mostly i was there to
serve what the chief of staff needed and
a lot of times what the chief of staff
needed was a reflection of what the
president's schedule was detailed to do
that day
so is it fair to say that you spoke
regularly in your position both with
members of congress and with senior
members of the trump administration
that's correct that's a fair assessment
sir
and would you say that in your work with
mr meadows you are typically in contact
with him and others in the white house
throughout the day
that's correct sir mr meadows and i were
in contact
almost
pretty much throughout every day
consistently
although so much of grave importance
happens in the west wing of the white
house
it's a quite a small building
above me
on the screen
you can see a map of the first floor
of the west wing of the white house
on the right
you can see the president's oval office
on the left
the chief of staff's office suite
within the chief of staff's office suite
is the heart of the west wing
was your desk
which was between the vice president's
office mrs kershner's office and the
oval office
ms hutchinson is
just an accurate depiction of where you
are located
it's accurate
it's a lot smaller than it looks
absolutely
[Music]
miss hutchinson this is a photo that
shows the short distance
between your office and the president's
oval office
and it only takes five to ten seconds or
so to walk down the hall
from your office to the oval office is
that right that's correct
thank you pursuant to the section 5 c 8
of house resolution 503 the chair
recognizes gentlewoman from wyoming miss
cheney for questions
thank you very much mr chairman
mr chairman we will begin today with an
exchange that first provided ms
hutchinson a tangible sense of the
ongoing planning for the events of
january 6th
on january 2nd four days before the
attack on our capitol president trump's
lead lawyer mr giuliani was meeting with
white house chief of staff mark meadows
and others
ms hutchinson do you remember mr
giuliani meeting with mr meadows on
january 2nd 2021
i do he met with mr meadows in the
evening of january 2nd 2021
and we understand that you walked mr
giuliani out of the white house that
night
and he talks to you about january 6th
what do you remember him saying
as mr giuliani and i were walking to his
vehicles that evening
he looked at me and said something to
the effect of
cast are you excited for the six it's
going to be a great day
i remember looking at him saying rudy
could you explain what's what's
happening on the six
and he had responded something to the
effect of we're going to the capitol
it's going to be great
the president's going to be there he's
going to look powerful he's he's going
to be with the members he's going to be
with the senators talk to the chief
about it talk to the chief about it he
knows about it
and did you go back
then up to the west wing and tell mr
meadows about your conversation with mr
giuliani i did after mr giuliani had
left the campus that evening i went back
up to our office and i found mr meadows
in his office on the couch
he was scrolling through his phone i
remember leaning against the doorway and
saying i had an interesting conversation
with rudy mark
it sounds like we're going to go to the
capitol
he didn't look up from his phone and
said something to the effect of
there's a lot going on guess
but i don't know things might get real
real bad on january 6.
uh miss hutchinson mr meadows is engaged
in litigation with the committee to try
to avoid testifying here
um what what was your reaction when he
said to you things might get real real
bad
in the days before january 2nd
i was apprehensive about the six i had
heard general plans for a rally uh i had
heard tentative movements to potentially
go to the capitol
but
when hearing rudy's take on january 6
and then marx responds
that was the first that evening was the
first moment
that i remember feeling
scared
and
nervous for what could happen
on january 6
and
i had a deeper concern for
what was
happening
with the planning aspects of
it thank you miss edgeson today we're
going to be focusing primarily on the
events of january 5th
and 6th at the white house
but to begin and to frame the discussion
i want to talk about a conversation that
you had with mr john ratcliffe
the director of national intelligence
and uh you had this conversation in
december of 2020.
mr ratcliffe was nominated by president
trump
to oversee u.s intelligence our u.s
intelligence community
and before his appointment mr ratcliffe
was a republican member of congress
as you will see on this clip director
ratcliffe's comments in december of 2020
were prescient
my understanding was mr
director radcliffe
didn't want much to do
with the post election period
dr rockford felt that
it wasn't something that the white house
should be pursuing
it felt it was dangerous for the
president's legacy
he
had expressed me that he was concerned
that it could spiral out of control
and
potentially
be dangerous
either
for our democracy or
the way that things were going for the
sex he was right
when you say
it wasn't something that should be
pursued what's the
trying
to fight the results of the election
finding missing ballots
pressuring
filing lawsuits in certain states
where there didn't seem to be
significant evidence
and reaching out to state legislatures
about
that so pretty much the way that the
white house was handling the
post-election period he felt that
there could be
dangerous repercussions
in terms of precedent set for elections
for our democracy
for the six you know he was hoping that
we would pretty astute analysis
so ms hutchinson uh now we're going to
turn to certain information that was
available before january 4th
and what the trump administration and
the president knew about the potential
for violence before january 6.
on the screen you will see an email
received by acting deputy attorney
general donahue on january 4th from the
national security division of the
department of justice
mr donoghue testified in our hearings
last week
the email identifies apparent planning
by those coming to washington on january
6th to quote occupy federal buildings
and discussions of quote invading the
capitol building here's what mr donohue
said to us
we knew that if you have
tens of thousands of very ups obsessed
people showing up in washington dc that
there was potential for violence
u.s secret service was looking
at similar information and watching the
planned demonstrations
in fact their intelligence division sent
several emails to white house personnel
like deputy chief of staff tony ornato
and the head of the president's
protective detail robert engel
including certain materials listing it
sounds like everybody knew it was likely
going to get violent at least days if
not weeks ahead of time planned
demonstrations including information
regarding the proud boys organizing and
planning to attend events on january 6th
although ms hutchinson has no detailed
knowledge of any planning involving the
proud boys for january 6th she did note
this
i recall
hearing
the word oath keeper and hearing the
word proud boys
closer to the planning of the january
6th rally when mr giuliani would be
around
january 3rd the capitol police issued a
special event assessment
in that document the capitol police
noted that the proud boys and other
groups planned to be in washington d.c
on january 6
and indicated that quote unlike previous
post-election protests the targets of
the pro-trump supporters are not
necessarily the counter protesters as
they were previously but rather congress
itself is the target on the sixth
of course we all know now that the proud
boys showed up on january 6th
marched from the washington monument to
the capitol that day
and led the riotous mob to invade and
occupy our capital
ms hutchinson i want to play you a clip
of one of our meetings
when you described a call on january 4th
that you received from national security
advisor robert o'brien on the same topic
potential violence on january 6th
i received a call
from
robert o'brien the national security
adviser
he had asked if he could speak with mr
meadows about
potential violent words of violence that
he was hearing
that were
potentially going to happen on the hill
on january 6th
i had asked if he had connected with
tony rornato because tony arnotto had a
conversation with him
with mark about that topic
robert had said i'll talk to tony and
then
um
i don't know if robert ever connected
with mark about
the issue
ms hutchinson can you describe for us mr
ornato's responsibilities as deputy
chief of staff
the deputy chief of staff positioned at
the white house for operations is
arguably one of the most important
positions that somebody can hold
they're in charge of all security
protocol for the campus and all
presidential protectees primarily the
president and the first family but
anything that requires security for
any individual that has
uh presidential protection so the chief
of staff or the
national security advisor
as well as the vice president's team too
tony would oversee all of that he was
the conduit for security protocol
between white house staff and the united
states secret service
thank you and you also described a brief
meeting between mr ornato and mr meadows
on the potential for violence
uh the meeting was on january 4th they
were talking about the potential for
violence on january 6. let's listen to a
clip of that testimony
remember mr ornato had talked to him
about intelligence reports
i remember mr renato coming in and
saying that we had intel reports saying
that there could potentially be violence
on this on the 6th
you also told us about reports of
violence and weapons that the secret
service were receiving on the night of
january 5th and throughout the day on
january 6th is that correct that's
correct
there are reports that police in
washington dc had arrested several
people with firearms or ammunition
following a separate pro-trump rally in
freedom plaza on the evening of january
5th are those some of the reports that
you recall hearing about
they are
of course the world now knows that the
people who attacked the capital on
january 6th had many different types of
weapons
when a president speaks the secret
service typically requires those
attending to pass through metal
detectors known as magnetometers or mags
for short
the select committee has learned that
people who willingly entered the
enclosed area for president trump's
speech
were screened so they could attend the
rally at the ellipse
they had weapons and other items that
were confiscated pepper spray knives
brass knuckles tasers body armor gas
masks batons blunt weapons
and those were just from the people who
chose to go through the security for the
president's event on the ellipse
not the several thousand members of the
crowd who refused to go through the mags
and watched from the lawn near the
washington monument
the select committee has learned about
reports from outside the magnetometers
and has obtained police radio
transmissions
identifying individuals with firearms
including ar-15s near the ellipse on the
morning of january 6. the trump
supporters have been saying nobody had
weapons
there's an individual who's in a tree
maybe a white male about six feet tall
thin build brown cowboy boots he's got
blue jeans and a blue jean jacket and
underneath the booty jacket the
complaints both saw a stock of ar-15
you can be with a group of individuals
about five eight five
eight other individuals
two of the individuals in that group at
the base of the tree near the porta
potties were wearing green fatigues
green olive giraffes now for these about
five eight five nine skinny
uh skinny white males brown cowboy boots
they had glock smile pistols in their
waistband
8736 with the message that subject
weapon on his right hip
hopefully he's in the tree
murder one make sure ppd knows they have
an elevated threat in the tree south
side of constitution avenue look for the
don't tread on me flag
american flag face mask cowboy boots
weapon on the right right side hip i got
three men walking down the street in
fatigue carrying ar-15
now that's a crime in dc right just to
even be there with those weapons isn't
it at 14th and independence
as you saw in those emails the first
report that we showed we now know was
sent in the 8 o'clock hour on january
6th this talked about people in the
crowd wearing ballistic helmets and body
armor carrying radio equipment and
military-grade backpacks tourists the
second report we showed you on the
screen was sent by the secret service in
the 11am hour and it addressed reports
of a man with a rifle near the ellipse
ms hutchinson in prior testimony you
described for us a meeting in the white
house around 10 a.m in the morning of
january 6th involving chief of staff
meadows and tony ornato were you in that
meeting
i was
let's listen to your testimony about
that meeting and then we'll have some
questions
i think the last time we talked you
mentioned that um
some of the weapons that people had
at the rally included
flag poles
oversized
sticks or flagpoles bear spray is there
anything else that you recall
hearing about the
people who would gather on their lips
hat i recall tony and i having a
conversation with mark probably around
10 am
10 15 am
where i remember
tony mentioning
knives
guns in the form of pistols and rifles
um bear spray body armor spears and
flagpoles spears were one item flagpoles
were one item and then tony had relayed
to me
something to the effect of
and these effing people are
fastening spears onto the ends of
flagpoles totally normal
hutchinson here's a clip of your
testimony regarding mr meadow's response
to learning that the rally attendees
were armed that day
what was mark's reaction mr meadow's
reaction
to this list of weapons that people had
in the crowd
when tony and i went in to talk to mark
that morning
mark was sitting on his couch and on his
phone which was something typical and i
remember tony just got right into it i
was like sorry i just want to let you
know and informed him like
this is how many people we have outside
the mags right now these are the weapons
that were known to have it's possible he
listed more weapons off that i just
don't recall
um
and gave him a brief but
inconcise explanation but also fairly
fairly thorough
and
i remember
distinctly mark not
looking up from his phone
i remember
tony finishing his explanation
and it's taking a few seconds for mark
to say something to the point where i
almost
said
mark did you hear him
um
and then bark
chimed in it was like
all right anything else still looking
down at his phone
and
tony looked at me and i looked at tony
and he said no sir do you have any
questions
it's like
what are you hearing
and i looked at tony and i was like sir
he just told you about what was
happening down at the rallies and he was
like yeah i know and then he looked up
and said
have you talked to the president
and tony said yes sir he's where to he
said all right good
he asked tony if tony had informed the
president yes and tony said yes he had
so ms hutchinson is it your
understanding that mr ornato told the
president about weapons at the rally on
the morning of january 6th
that's what mr renato relayed to me
and here's how you characterize mr
meadow's general response when people
raised concerns about what could happen
on january 6th
so at the time in the days leading up to
the six there were lots of public
reports about how things might go bad
on the sex even the potential for
violence
if i'm hearing you correctly what stands
out to you is that mr meadows did not
share those concerns or at least did not
act on those concerns
did not act on those concerns would be
accurate
but other people raised him to to him
like in this exchange you mentioned that
this tornado pulled them aside that's
correct
ms hutchinson
we're going to show now an exchange of
texts between you and deputy chief of
staff ornato
um and these text messages uh were
exchanged while you were at the ellipse
in one text you write but the crowd
looks good from this vantage point as
long as we get the shot
he was effing furious
and the text messages also stressed that
president trump kept mentioning the otr
and off the record movement we're going
to come back and ask you about that in a
minute
but could you tell us first of all who
it is in the text who was furious
the he and that text that i was
referring to was the
president and uh why was he furious miss
hutchinson
he was furious because he wanted the
arena that we had on the ellipse to be
maxed out at capacity for
all attendees
the advanced team had relayed to him
that
the mags were free-flowing
everybody who wanted to come in isn't
that amazing trump's been saying for a
year that that was the biggest crowd
ever at any political event the truth is
that day he was furious that weren't
that many people there i i was there yes
in the motor game and were you backstage
with the president and other members of
his staff and family i was
and you told us ms hutchinson about
particular comments that you heard while
you were in the tent area
when we were in the offstage announce
area tent behind the stage
he was very concerned about the shot
meaning the photograph that we would get
because the rally space wasn't full
um
one of the reasons which i've previously
stated was because
he wanted it to be full and for people
to not
feel excluded because they've come
forward to watching at the rally
um and he felt the mags were at fault
for not letting everybody in but another
leading reason and
likely the primary reason is because he
wanted it full and he was angry that we
weren't letting people through the mags
with weapons
what the secret service deemed his
weapons and wait he wanted the people
with weapons to be right up by the stage
is that what she's saying it's tent
i was part of a conversation
i was in the phys i was in the vicinity
of a conversation where i overheard the
president say something to the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing bags away oh my let my people in
they can march the capital from here let
the people in take that bags away oh and
he knew they'd be taking the weapons to
the capitol
just to be clear miss hutchinson is it
your understanding that the president
wanted to take the mags away and said
that the armed individuals were not
there to hurt him
that's a fair assessment
the issue wasn't with the amount of
space available in the official rally
area
only but instead that people did not
want to have to go through the mags
let's listen to a portion of what you
told us about that wow
in this particular instance it wasn't
the capacity of our space it was
the mags and the people that didn't want
to come through and that's what tony had
been trying to relate to him that
morning you know it's not the issues
that we encountered on the campaign we
have enough space or
they don't want to come in right now
they they have weapons they don't want
confiscated by the secret service
and they're fine on the mall they can
see you on the mall they want to march
straight to the capitol
from the mall
the president apparently wanted all
attendees inside the official rally
space and repeatedly said quote they're
not here to hurt me
and and just to to be clear so
um
he was told again
in that conversation or was he told
again in that conversation that people
couldn't come through the mags because
they had weapons correct
and um
that people
and his response was to say they can
march to the capitol from
from the ellipse something defective
take the effing mags away they're not
here to hurt me
let them in let my people in they can
march to the capitol after the rally is
over they can march from they can march
from the ellipse take the effing mags
away
then they can march the capitol wow
ms hutchinson what we saw when those
clips were playing were photos provided
by the national archives showing the
president in the offstage tent before
his speech on the ellipse you were in
some of those photos as well
and
i just want to confirm that that is when
you heard the president say the people
with weapons weren't there to hurt him
and that he wanted the secret service to
remove the magnetometers that's correct
in the photos that you displayed we were
standing towards the front of the tent
with the tvs
really close to where he would walk out
to go onto the stage
these conversations happened
two to three minutes before he took the
stage that morning
let's reflect on that for a moment
president trump was aware that a number
of the individuals in the crowd had
weapons and were wearing body armor and
here's what president trump instructed
the crowd to do
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you
we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going to walk down to the capitol
and we will be in the crowd
did proceed to the capitol it soon
became apparent to the secret service
including the secret service teams in
the crowd
along with white house staff the
security at the capitol would not be
sufficient
i've had
two or three phone conversations with mr
renato when we were at the ellipse
and then i had
four men on mr meadows detail with me
in between
those individuals and then a few other
the bodies on the ground just secret
service doing advance
they were getting notifications through
their radios and mr ornato in one phone
conversation had called me and said make
sure the chief knows that they're
getting closer to the capital it's
um
they're having trouble stacking bodies
ms hutchinson when you you said they
were having trouble stacking bodies did
you mean that law enforcement at the
capitol
needed more people to defend the capital
from the rioters
it was becoming clear to us and to the
secret service that capitol police
officers were getting overrun at the
security barricades outside of the
capitol building
and they were having short they were
short people to defend the building
against the rioters
and
you mentioned that mr ornato was
conveying this to you because he wanted
you to tell mr meadows
so did you did you tell mr meadows uh
that people were getting closer to the
capitol and that capitol police was
having difficulty
after i had the conversation with mr
meadows
mr after i had the conversation with mr
ornato i went to have the discussion
with mr meadows he was in a secure
vehicle at the time making a call
so when i had gone over to the car i
went to open the door to let him know
and he had immediately shut it i don't
know who he was speaking with
it wasn't something that he regularly
did especially when i would go over to
give him information
so i was a bit taken aback
but i didn't think much of it
and thinking that i was would be able to
have the conversation with him a few
moments later
and were you able to have that
conversation a few moments later
probably about 20 to 25 minutes later
there was another period in between
where he shut the door again um and then
when he finally got out of the vehicle
we had the conversation but at that
point there was a backlog of information
that he should have been made aware of
and so you opened the door to the
control car and mr meadows pulled it
shut that's correct and he did that two
times that's correct
and when you
finally were able to give mr meadows the
information um about the violence at the
capitol what was his reaction
he almost had a lack of reaction
i remember him saying
all right
something to the effect of
how much longer
does the president have left in this
speech
again
much of this information about the
potential for violence
was known or learned before the onset of
the violence early enough for president
trump to take steps to prevent it
he could for example have urged the
crowd at the ellipse not to march to the
capitol he could have condemned the
violence immediately once it began
or he could have taken multiple other
steps
but as we will see today and in later
hearings president trump had something
else in mind
one other question at this point ms
hutchinson were you aware of concerns
that white house counsel pat sipoloni or
eric hirschmann had about the language
president trump used in his elipse
speech
there were many discussions the morning
of the six about the rhetoric
of the speech that day
in my conversations with mr hirschman he
had relayed that
we would be
foolish to include language that had
been included at the president's request
which
headlines
along
to the effect of
fight for trump we're gonna march the
capitol i'll be there with you
fight for me fight for what we're doing
fight for the movement
um
things about vice president at the time
too both mr hershman and white house
counsel's office were urging the
speechwriters to not include that
language
for legal concerns and also for the
optics of what it could portray the
president wanting to do that day
and we just heard the president say that
he would be with his supporters as they
marched to the capitol
even though
he did not end up going he certainly
wanted to
some have questioned whether president
trump genuinely planned to come here to
the capitol on january 6.
in his book mark meadows falsely wrote
that after president trump gave his
speech on january 6 he told mr meadows
he was quote speeding medi speaking
metaphorically about the walk to the
capitol right as you will see donald
trump was not speaking metaphorically
as we heard earlier rudy giuliani told
miss hutchinson that mr trump plans to
travel to the capitol on january 6th
i want to pause for just a moment
to ask you ms hutchinson to explain some
of the terminology you will hear today
we've heard you use two different terms
to describe plans for the president's
movement
the capitol or anywhere else one of
those is a scheduled movement and
another one is otr could you describe
for us what each of those mean
a scheduled presidential movement is on
his official schedule
it's notified to the press and to a wide
range of staff that will be traveling
with him it's known to the public known
to the secret service and they're able
to coordinate the movement
days in advance
an off-the-record movement is confined
to the knowledge of a very very small
group of advisors and staff
typically a very small group of staff
would travel with him
mostly that are just included in the
national security package
you can pull an off to off the record
movement together in
less than an hour
um
it's a way to kind of circumvent
having
to release it to the press if that's the
goal of it or
to not have to have as many security
parameters put in place ahead of time to
make the movement happen
thank you
and let's turn back now to the
president's plans to travel to the
capitol on january 6.
we know that white house counsel pat
sipoloni was concerned about the legal
implications of such a trip and he
agreed with the secret service that it
shouldn't happen
as hutchinson did you have any
conversations with pat sipoloni about
his concerns about the president going
to the capitol on january 6th
on january 3rd mr sipoloni had
approached me knowing that mark had
raised
the prospect of going up to the capitol
on january 6.
mr sipoloni and i had a brief private
conversation where
he said to me
we need to make sure that this doesn't
happen
this would be
a legally a terrible idea for us
we have serious legal concerns if we go
up to the capitol that day
and he then urged me
to continue relaying that to mr meadows
because
it's my understanding that
mr sipoloni thought that mr meadows was
indeed pushing this along with the
president
and we understand miss hutchinson that
you also spoke to mr sipoloni on the
morning of the sixth as you were about
to go to the rally on the ellipse
and mr cipoloni said something to you
like make sure the movement to the
capitol does not happen is that correct
that's correct i saw mr sipoloni right
before i walked out onto west exec that
morning
and mr cipolloni said something to the
effect of
please make sure we don't go up to the
capitol cassidy keep in touch with me
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable if we make that
movement happen
and do you remember which crimes mr
sipolonia was concerned with
in the days leading up to the six we had
conversations about potentially
obstructing justice or
defrauding the electoral account wow
they knew exactly what they did let's
hear
about some of those concerns that you
mentioned earlier uh in one of your
interviews with us
having a private conversation with pat
late in the afternoon of
third or the fourth
um
that pat was concerned it would look
like we were
obstructing justice
for obstructing the electoral college
count and i apologize for probably not
being
very
far with my legal terms here but
um
that it would look like we were
obstructing what was happening on
capitol hill and
he was also worried that it would look
like we were inciting a riot
or encouraging a riot exactly what they
did at the capitol wow
in fact in the days before january 6 and
on january 6 itself president trump
expressed to multiple white house aides
that he wanted to go to the capitol
after his speech here's what various
white house aides have told the
committee about the president's desire
to go to the capitol
did the president tell you this that he
wanted to speak at the capitol correct
yes
during the meeting in the dining room
did the the idea of the president
um proceeding or walking to the capitol
on the six after his speech come up
walking to the capitol no
driving to the capitol
it came up
okay how did it come up and what was
discussed
you brought it up you said i want to go
down to the capitol what about him
marching to the capitol on the sixth um
yes
tell us about that
so
this is kind of a general thing i mean
to get into the specifics of it i
i was aware of the
desire of the president
to potentially
uh
march to the
or or accompany
the
rally attendees to the capitol can you
imagine when did you first hear about
this idea of the president accompanying
rally attendees to the capitol on the
sixth well this was at the six this was
during the
um
after he finished his remarks
when the president said that he would be
going to the capitol during his speech
on the ellipse the secret service
scrambled to find a way for him to go
we know this from witnesses
and the secret service
also from messages among staff on the
president's national security council
the nsc staff were monitoring the
situation in real time and you can see
how the situation evolved in the
following chat log that the committee
has obtained
as you can see
nsc staff believed that mogul
the president
was quote going to the capitol
and quote they are finding the best
route now
from these chats we also know the staff
learned of the attack on the capitol in
real time
when president trump left the ellipse
stage at 110 the staff knew
that rioters had invaded the inaugural
stage and capitol police were calling
for all available officers to respond
when republican leader kevin mccarthy
heard the president say he was going to
the capitol
he called you miss hutchinson
isn't that right
that's correct
and in this text message
you told tony ornato quote mccarthy just
called me too
and do you guys think you're coming to
my office
tell us about the call that day with
leader mccarthy during the president's
speech on the ellipse
i was still in the tent behind the stage
and when you're behind the stage you
can't really hear what's going on
in front of you
so when mr mccarthy called me with this
information
i answered the call and he sounded
rushed but also
frustrated and angry at me and i was
confused because i didn't know what the
president had just said
um
he then explained
the president just said he's marching to
the capitol you told me this whole week
you aren't coming up here why would you
lie to me
i said i'm i'm not lying i wasn't lying
to you sir i
we're not going to the capitol and he
said well
he just said it on stage cassidy figure
it out don't come up here
i said i'll i'll
i'll run the traps on this now i'll
shoot you a text i can assure you we're
not coming up to the capitol we've
already made that decision
he pressed a little bit more
believing me but i think frustrated that
the president had said that
and we ended the phone conversation
after that
i called mr oronato to reconfirm that we
weren't going to the capitol
and
which was also in our text messages
i sent mr mccarthy another text
telling him
the affirmative that we were not going
up to the capitol and he didn't respond
after that
and we understand miss hutchinson that
the plans for the president to come to
the capitol
had included discussions at some point
about
what the president would do
when he came up to the capitol on
january 6.
let's look at a clip
of one of your interviews discussing
that issue with the committee when you
were talking about a scheduled movement
did
anyone say what the president wanted to
do when he got here
no
not that i can specifically remember i
remember
i remember hearing a few different ideas
discussed with
between
mark and scott perry marco rudy giuliani
i don't know
which
conversations were elevated to the
president i don't know
what he personally wanted to do when he
went up to the capitol that day
um
you know i i know that
there were discussions about him having
another speech outside of the capitol
before going in
i know that there is a conversation
about him going into the house chamber
at one point oh my god
as we've all just heard in the days
leading up to january 6th
on the day of the speech both before and
during
and after the rally speech president
trump
was pushing his staff to arrange for him
to come up here to the capitol during
the electoral vote count
let's turn now to what happened in the
president's vehicle
when the secret service told him he
would not be going to the capitol after
his speech
first here is the president's motorcade
leaving the ellipse after his speech on
january 6th
miss hutchinson
when you return to the white house in
the motorcade after the president's
speech where did you go
when i returned to the white house i
walked upstairs towards the chief of
staff's office and i noticed mr ronato
lingering outside of the office once we
had made eye contact he quickly waved me
to go into his office which was just
across the hall from mine
when i went in he shut the door i
noticed bobby angle who's the head of mr
trump's security detail sitting in a
chair
looking somewhat discombobulated a
little lost
i looked at tony and he had said
did you i think hear what happened in
the beast
i said no tony i just got back
what happened
tony proceeded to tell me that
when the president got in the beast he
was under the impression from mr meadows
that the off the record movement to the
capitol was still possible and likely to
happen but that bobby had more
information
so once the president had gotten into
the vehicle with bobby
he thought that they were going up to
the capitol and when bobby had relayed
to him
we're not you don't have the assets to
do it it's not secure we're going back
to the west wing
the president had
very strong a very angry response to
that
um
tony described him as being irate right
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing sir
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle oh my god mr
when mr ronaldo had recounted this story
to me he had motioned towards his
clavicles trump attacked secret service
and was mr engel
in the room as mr ornato told you this
story he was
did mr engel
correct or disagree with any part of the
story from mr ornato mr engel did not
correct or disagree with any part of the
story
did mr engel or mr ornato ever after
that tell you that what mr ornato had
just said was untrue
neither mr ornato nor mr engel told me
ever that it was untrue
and despite this altercation this
physical altercation
during the ride back to the white house
president trump
still demanded to go to the capitol
here's what kaylee mciney the white
house press secretary at the time wrote
in her personal notes and told the
committee about president trump's desire
to go to the capitol
after returning to the white house
when you wrote potus wanted to walk to
the capitol
was that based solely on what the
president said during his speech or
anything that he or anybody else said
afterwards
so to the best of my recollection i
believe when we got back to the white
house he said he wanted to physically
walk
with the marchers and according to my
notes he then said uh you'd be fine with
just writing the beast but so that's my
recollection he wanted to be
a part of the march in some fashion
okay and just for the record the beast
refers to the presidential limousine
yes
president trump did not go to the
capitol that day
we understand that he blamed mark
meadows for that
so prior to leaving the rally site
when he got off the stage
and everybody was making the movement
back to the motorcade i had overheard mr
meadows say to him then as i had prior
to mr trump taking the stage that
morning
um
that he was still working on
getting an off the record movement to
the capitol so when mr trump took the
stage
he was under the impression by mr
meadows that
it was still possible so when he got off
the stage
i had relayed to mr meadows that i had
another conversation with tony the
movement was still not possible
mr meadow said okay
and then as they proceeded to go to the
motorcade
um
and
mr meadows had reiterated we're going to
work on a certain body bobby has more
information
mark got into his vehicle to my
understanding trump got into the beast
and
after we'd all arrived back at the white
house
later in the day
it had been released me via mark that
the president wasn't happy that bobby
didn't pull it off for him and that mark
didn't work hard enough to get the
movement on the books
wow
the physical altercation that ms
hutchinson described in the presidential
vehicle
was not the first time that the
president
had become very angry about issues
relating to the election
on december 1 2020 attorney general barr
said in an interview that the department
of justice had not not found evidence of
widespread election fraud sufficient to
change the outcome of the election
ms hutchinson how did the president
react to hearing that
news around the time that i understand
the ap article went live
i remember hearing noise coming from
down the hallway so i poked my head out
of the office i saw the valet walking
towards our office he had said
get the chief down to the dining room
the president wants him
so mark went down to the dining room
came back to the office a few minutes
later
after mark had returned i left the
office and went down to the dining room
and i noticed that the door was propped
open and the valley was inside the
dining room changing the tablecloth off
of the dining room table
he motioned for me to come in
and then pointed towards the front of
the room near the fireplace mantle and
the tv where
i first noticed there was ketchup
dripping down the wall
and there's a shattered porcelain plate
on the floor
the valet had articulated that the
president was
extremely angry
at
the attorney general's ap interview
and had thrown his lunch against the
wall
um chicken fingers and ketchup probably
which was causing them to have to clean
up so i grabbed a towel and started
wiping the catch up off the wall to help
the valet out
um
and he said something to the effect of
he's really ticked off about this
i would stay clear of him
for right now he's really really ticked
off about this right now
and miss hutchinson
was this the only instance that you are
aware of where the president
threw dishes
it's not
and are there other instances in the
dining room that you recall where he
expressed his anger
yes with barbecue there were several
times throughout my tenure with the
chief of staff that i was aware
of him either throwing dishes or
flipping the tablecloth
um
to let all the contents of the table go
onto the floor and
likely break or
go everywhere stability
and miss hutchinson attorney general
barr described to the committee the
president's
angry reaction when he finally met with
president trump
let's listen
and i said look i i
know that you're dissatisfied with me
and i'm glad to offer my resignation and
he pounded the table very hard everyone
sort of jumped and he said accept it
mr chairman i reserve
wow gentlewoman reserves the chair
requests those in the hearing room to
remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
our witness from the room
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
wow so major revelations catch up or as
i know it ketchup
ending up on the wall after donald trump
and a childish tirade maybe involving
dinosaur-shaped chicken nuggets
uh started launching food around like a
toddler
wow
wow wow wow
i'm curious whether trump is posting
anything to his social platform truth
essential
let's see here
what is he posting if anything
[Music]
uh nope nothing from trump what an
insane insane
so the testimony is that trump
physically attacked a secret service
agent in his vehicle when they refused
to take him to the riot
and also attempted to commandeer the
vehicle
um
i have to tell you i i did not expect
this i did not expect this
um
wow
they'll be back in um
in about nine minutes and we'll just try
to get caught up my goodness
thank you to everyone signing up and
supporting welcome on twitch stoic
stranger getting a twitch prime
subscription charles wheeland
metapotamus
jake the android a bunch of membership
dumps from c missile and metapotamus
and so many people signing up folks
the coupon code supportthestream
joinpakman.com
indite is today's coupon code i want to
say thanks to robert grant as well as
ben nolan for signing up with that code
also thanks to sam smith dylan reese
brandon harwood cameron idolat
and brown salvador perez thanks to all
of you for signing up and supporting
today's stream at join joinpakman.com so
great to have you here
an incredible series of allegations here
incredible series of allegations of
course the coupon code works i will
thank every single one of you who uses
it on my website
i'm also thanks to puppy.exe
and blooming basil
for the twitch prime subscriptions let's
see what's on people's minds here
so i guess desantis will be our next
president says operator
fair play to that woman she's doing so
well keeping a straight face you can see
her fighting the urge to smirk yeah when
it got to the catch-up
it really uh she seemed to be struggling
to maintain her composure
right now trump's fridge is on his wall
the thing is you have to give toddlers
plastic wear for this very reason yeah
they trump shouldn't be eating on
ceramic plates
doesn't seem logical at all
trump posted on truth social
let's see here okay trump has a post oh
wow trump is losing it look at this
folks
trump
extraordinarily
triggered i hardly know who this person
cassidy hutchinson is
other than i heard very negative things
about her a total phony and a leaker
and when she requested to go with
certain others of the team to florida
after my having served a full term in
office i personally turned her request
down why did she want to go with us if
she felt we were so terrible i
understand she was very upset and angry
that i didn't want her to go or a member
of the team she is bad news so
this is just a disgruntled former
employee guys that's all it is nothing
to see here just another disgruntled
person who's upset with scrumps that's
all can't believe a word of it now if
you leak stuff it's the truth
right she's leaking things he's not
saying she's making it up
he's saying she's a leaker
your newborn has better manners than
trump congrats on the baby thanks man
yeah that's true yeah she's not launched
a dinosaur attendees anywhere yet
think the circuit secret service agent
needed elements of medico after trump
attacked him also can i get a shout out
for my girlfriend ari yes ari
congratulations on dating jay dead
i can only imagine
the
pre-marital bliss you're experiencing
let's recap says joseph trump knew the
crowd was armed was mad the crowd wasn't
bigger assaulted the secret service when
they wouldn't let him lead the mob to
the capitol when will trump be charged
for his numerous crimes
that's why the coupon code is indict
guys
uh and membership starting to dump in
thanks to adam snodgrass for signing up
at joinpackman.com
and thanks to terry schwerin for gifting
a subscription that puts us at 80. folks
i think we have the testicular and
ovarian fortitude to make it to one
hundred
i really do i really do
um i second the idea from earlier that
someone had about a coupon named ku on
right
absolutely
absolutely extremely important things
being said there
let's see if we have any voicemails
they're going to be back in five minutes
anybody calling in here
let's see
david david from oklahoma i'm watching
your live stream and the reveal that
trump actually
wanted to go to the capitol and like
lead the charge like some fat napoleon
against the united states is really
unbelievable
and i hope that you cover all this uh
and break it down and congratulations
on your new baby
uh i'm a little bit past that
one-year-old and it just gets better and
better so soak it in
love what you do thanks
a very powerful
declaration from oklahoma there
i appreciate that very much here's
another voicemail although i don't know
that it's relevant to the hearing
hey there i wanted you to know that the
murder rate for transgender people in
the us is four times higher than it is
for everybody else
right no we do know we do know that it
is not today's subject matter that's for
sure and we will ban men
yeah
would you like some gray poupon with
your wall sir
yeah trump reportedly
does not like mayonnaise
nor mustard on the wall only ketchup and
extremely sugary barbecue sauces you
know it's funny just earlier people said
do you think trump likes vegetables and
i was like trump probably likes
french fries
and either tomato sauce
or ketchup and then all of a sudden we
now have testimony under oath that trump
smeared ketchup all over the wall
so that is something else i want to say
thank you to naki cruz for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
and michael kimsel thank you new members
number 81 and 82. today's coupon code is
indict welcome everybody we are in a
very brief break and then we will resume
testimony with cassidy hutchinson who
has made some incredible revelations the
funniest revelations are about trump and
his food habits
smearing ketchup on the wall
the most disturbing revelation is that
trump
uh want new people were armed and wanted
them to be allowed in not having to go
through metal detectors so that then
they would be able to go armed to the
capitol
and then the most bizarre one
is that trump attacked one of his own
secret service agents and tried to
commandeer his vehicle
beyond belief beyond belief thanks to
andro filer and lurch el cazzo who
between the two of them just dumped in
15 more twitch subscriptions putting us
at 97 also under the screen grabbing a
subscription putting us at 98
and something very very special here
luke jamula just signed up on my website
is new member number 99
and andrew avr drums gifting a
membership and that is number 100 folks
we've done it
let's go for 150 because it's just that
type of day
general anubis says as funny as it is to
joke about the tantrums this is very
similar behavior to other dictators such
as hitler not funny to think about oh oh
trump's an authoritarian nightmare
it's just cartoonishly so
fish sticks and cocktail sauce are
covering the walls of mural lago today
he's watching today's hearing and
posting during the break he is indeed
do you think trump even knows how to
drive a car has he ever driven before in
his life i wondered about that i don't
think trump knows how to drive i really
don't
remember trump eats steak with ketchup
and well done can you is there any
greater listen
we could charge trump with a lot of
things he may end up charged uh because
of what he did in in georgia i need 11
000 votes give me a break yeah but well
done steak with ketchup is a war crime
do not be uh confused
it is absolutely
absolutely a war crime it is completely
bonkers
um
okay
david is it bad if i think this is
hilarious i'm disgusted amused and
amazed history in the making i want to
see our orange man behind bars yeah no i
mean listen there are there are culinary
crimes being committed here by trump
which are funny but also i mean
assaulting a secret service agent
knowing that there are armed people and
saying just let them in don't even
bother with the metal detect it's it's
every aspect of it is crazy
every aspect
more calls uh dumping in david sir
you're you're totally off basis do i
throw those nuggets against the wall
they were for ivanka and jared they
weren't kosher
okay there was some pig in there
potentially
unhappy through the walls demanded
kosher nuggets for his very deeply
religious children trump is deeply
spiritual that's exactly right and when
he found out that there were non-kosher
nuggets being served
uh he found it to be an affront
to uh jared and ivanka by the way i
don't even think jared and ivanka keep
kosher
i know i know they're jewish but i don't
think they even keep kosher it's just a
joke
rich e with the twitch prime
subscription is new member number 101
today as we stand by i want to say thank
you to andrew avr drums who is gifting
even more subscriptions let's see he's
up to two more
uh i appreciate that that puts us at 103
and then a big thank you to tiffany
jorgens
and abby shirky for the twit uh for the
website membership signing up at
joinpakman.com and lastly another gift
oh god i don't know how to pronounce
this
is it
i have i am sorry but it is a gifted
membership on the website and it is
number 106 and i really do appreciate
that
um
other super chats coming in a co-worker
took their life a few weekends ago oh my
goodness was a huge alt-righter friday
he mentioned trying to escape america
because of world war three the alt-right
pipeline is a sickness wow that sounds
complicated
and that that sounds terrible
um
very very sorry to hear that
thanks to
ewy
geez for the twitch prime subscription
number 107 we are moments away from this
resuming and a very very wild first uh
first section
um more voicemails coming in about the
hearings
hi david my name is nico i am from
southern california yes currently
watching nico's called in before live
stream
um regarding the january 6th committee
with all of the new evidence that they
have presented has your opinion about
trump going to jail changed
um do you think he's going to serve time
what do you think will come about um do
guys i still don't think trump's going
to prison i mean i don't know i i know
that there's people who get mad at me
when i say that but i just i just don't
and i hope i'm wrong
i really do
um
let's see
here's another voicemail although i
think this is about a clip from
yesterday hey a minute 25 seconds into
the interview of the man talking about
brushing their teeth
and what you use or not using i i
always crack up i can't get i can't keep
it in when you had said that's exactly
what i'd asked oh yeah that's a good
question i would have said to the guy
okay smile
because uh
if they're uneducated fools they won't
have enough knowledge to brush their
teeth
that actually is interesting i wonder
what the guy that we played a clip
yesterday of a trump guy
saying something about how
fluoride is poison and
toothpaste is poison and all these
different things it would have been
interesting to get a look at his teeth
that actually that that's actually a
really good point it didn't even occur
to me did not even occur to me
very very fair point i want to say thank
you to fatty mcblunts for the twitch
prime subscription number 108 fatty says
does anyone know the two people trump is
following on truth social i don't want
to make an account to find out let's
check that out
trump is following two people on troth
he's following truth social
and truth social support
truth essential yeah
wait a second do i have my uh
you know mike did me on 60 minutes oh
yeah okay
man
virtue
cycling a rhino named mitt romney
we've endorsed jp right j.d mandel
no more dropbox
drop boxes
if you care about law and auto i want
law and auto umbrella and liability i
care about all of those different things
and i demand answers folks i demand
answers law auto liability umbrella
business liability
i want to know about all of it folks the
website is under stress because people
are signing up like crazy thanks to
mikko jenkins brian ward
and joshua martin for the new
memberships putting us at 111
we have a borderline illegal discount
code today the code is indict the
meaning of the code should be obvious to
everybody at this point should be no
surprise whatsoever
no surprise whatsoever
um okay we are back in session wyoming
vice chair cheney
thank you mr chairman
before we turn to what ms hutchinson saw
and heard in the white house during the
violent attack on the capitol on january
6th
let's discuss certain communications
white house chief of staff
mark meadows had on january 5th please
president trump's associate
roger stone attended rallies during the
afternoon and the evening of january 5th
in washington d.c
on january 5th and 6th
mr stone was photographed with multiple
members of the oath keepers who were
allegedly serving as his security detail
as we now know
multiple members of that organization
have been charged with or pled guilty to
crimes associated with january 6th
mr stone has invoked his fifth amendment
privilege against self-incrimination
before this committee
general michael flynn has also taken the
fifth before this committee
mr stone previously had been convicted
of other federal crimes
unrelated to january 6th
general flynn had pleaded guilty to a
felony charge also predating and
unrelated to january 6.
president trump pardoned general flynn
just weeks after the presidential
election
and in july of 2020 he commuted the
sentence roger stone was to serve
the night before january 6th president
trump instructed his chief of staff mark
meadows to contact both roger stone and
michael flynn
regarding what would play out the next
day
miss hutchinson is it your understanding
that president trump asked mark meadows
to speak with roger stone and general
flynn on january 5th
that's correct that is my understanding
and ms hutchinson is it your
understanding that mr meadows called mr
stone on the fifth
i'm under the impression that mr meadows
did complete both a call to
mr stone and general flynn the evening
of the fifth
and do you know what they talked about
that evening ms hutchinson i'm not sure
is it your understanding that mr
giuliani mr eastman and others had set
up what has been called quote a war room
at the willard hotel on the night of the
fifth
i was aware of that the night of the
fifth
and do you know if mr meadows ever
intended to go to the willard hotel on
the night of the fifth mr meadows had a
conversation with me where he wanted me
to work with secret service on a
movement from the white house to the
bullard hotel so he could attend the
meeting
or meetings with mr giuliani and his
associates in the war room
and what was your view as to whether or
not mr meadows should go to the willard
that night
i had made it clear to mr meadows that i
didn't believe it was a smart idea for
him to go to the willard hotel that
night
i wasn't sure everything that was going
on at the willard hotel although i knew
enough about what
mr giuliani and his associates were
pushing during this period
i didn't think that it was something
appropriate for the white house chief of
staff to attend or to consider
involvement and
i made that clear to mr meadows
throughout the afternoon he mentioned a
few more times going up
to the willard hotel that evening
and then eventually dropped the subject
the night of
the fifth and said that he would dial in
instead
so general flynn has
appeared before this committee
and when he appeared before our
committee he took the fifth
let's briefly view a clip of general
mike flynn taking the fifth amendment
uh general flynn do you believe the
violence on january 6 was justified
yes
could you repeat the question please
yes general flynn do you believe the
violence on january 6 was justified
is that
can i get a clarification it's not a
moral question you're asking the
question i'm asking
both
i said i said
do you believe the violence on january 6
was justified morally
you believe the violence on january 6
was justified legally
general flynn do you believe in the
peaceful transition of power in the
united states of america
oh god let's move on now to january 6th
and the conduct of donald trump and mark
meadows during the attack on the capitol
ms hutchinson i'd like now for us to
listen to a description
your description of what transpired in
the west wing during the attack
for context in this clip you describe
the time frame starting at about 2 p.m
so i remember
mark being alone in his office for
quite some time and you know
i know we've spoken about ben williamson
going in at one point and i don't
personally remember ben going and i
don't doubt that he had gone in
um
but i remember him being alone in his
office for most of the afternoon around
two o'clock to 205
around two o'clock to 205
you know we were watching the tv and i
could see that the riders were getting
closer and closer to the capitol mark
still hadn't popped out of his office or
said anything about it so that's when i
went into his office i saw that he was
sitting on his couch
on his cell phone
same as the morning where he was just
kind of scrolling and typing um
i said hey are you watching the tv chief
because tv was small and i you can see
it but i didn't know if he was really
paying attention
watching the tv chief he was like
yeah
the writers are getting really close
have you talked to the president he said
no he wants to be alone right now
still looking at his phone
so i start to get frustrated because
i sort of felt like i was watching a
this is not a great comparison but a bad
car accident that was about to happen
where
you can't stop it but
are you after you want to be able to do
something
and i just remember i remember thinking
in that moment
mark needs to snap out of this and i
don't know how to snap him out of this
but he he needs to care
and i just remember i blurted out i said
mark do you know where jim's at right
now
and he looked up at me at that point
said jim i said
marcus he was on the floor a little
while ago giving a floor speech did you
listen he said yeah it was real good did
you like it and i said yeah
do you know where he's at right now
he said no i haven't heard from him
you might want to check in with him mark
and he'll remember pointing at the tv
and the rioters are getting close
they might get in
and he looked at me and said
something to the effect of
all right i'll give him a call
not long after the rioters broke into
the capitol
you described what happened with white
house counsel pat cipolloni
no more than a minute
a minute and a half later i see pastor
bologna barreling down the hallway
towards our office
and
rushed right in looked at me
said is mark in his office and i said
yes
he just looked at me and started shaking
his head and went over open mark's
office door
stood there with the door propped open
and said something see if mark is still
sitting on his phone i remember like
lansing and he's still sitting on his
phone
and i remember pat saying to him
something to the effect of
the riders had gotten to the capitol
mark we need to go down and see the
president now
and mark looked up at it and said he
doesn't want to do anything bad
and pat said something to the effect of
and very clearly
had
said this to mark something's the effect
of
mark something needs to be done or
people are going to die and the blood's
going to be on your effing hands this is
getting out of control i'm going down
there and at that point mark stood up
from his couch both his phones in his
hand he had his glasses on so
he walked out with pat
he put both of his phones on my desk
and said let me know if jim calls
and they walked out and went down to the
dining room
a few minutes later representative
jordan called back
a couple minutes later so likely around
between 2 15
225 i know the tweet went out at 2 24 i
don't remember if i was
there when the tweet went out or if it
happened right afterwards but
jim had called i answered the phone
said one second he
knew it was i guess he knew this man i
introduced myself but i i don't remember
if he called my cell phone or if he had
called one of marx
um
but i answered the phones in one second
mark's on the hall i'm gonna go hand the
phones and he said okay
so i went down i asked the valet if
mark was in the dining room
valerie said yes i opened the door to
the
dining room
briefly stepped in
to get mark's attention
showed him the phone like flipped the
phone his way so you could see it said
jim jordan
he had stepped to where i was standing
there holding the door open
took the phone talking to jim with the
door still propped open
so i took a few steps back so i probably
was
two feet from mark he was standing in
the doorway going to the oval office
dining room
they had a brief conversation and
in the crossfires you know i heard
briefly like what they were talking
about but in the background i had heard
conversations in the oval dining room at
the point at that point
talking about the hang mike pence chance
here we go
that clip ended ms hutchinson with you
recalling that you heard the president
mr meadows and the white house counsel
discussing the hang mike pence chance
here we go and then you described for us
what happened next
wasn't until
mark hung up the phone handed it back to
me i went back to my desk
a couple minutes later
him and pat came back possibly eric
hershman too i'm pretty sure eric
hershey was there
but i'm i'm confident it was pat that
was there
um
i remember pat saying something to the
effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling for the vice
president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong wow
to which pat said something
this is acting crazy
we need to be doing something more
briefly stepped into wow mark's office
and when mark had said something but
market said something to the effect of
he doesn't think they're doing anything
wrong
knowing what i had heard
briefly in the dining room
coupled with pat discussing the hang
mike pence chance
in the lobby of our office and then
mark's response i understood there
to be the riders in the capital that
were
chanting
for the vice president to be hung
so trump agreed
on this point
as rioters chanted hang mike pence
the president of the united states
donald trump
said that quote mike deserves it right
and that those rioters were not doing
anything wrong
this is a sentiment that he has
expressed at other times as well in an
interview
with abc news correspondent jonathan
carl
president trump was asked
about the supporters chanting hang mike
pence last year
instead of condemning them the former
president defended them
because it's it's common sense
it's common sense
that
you're supposed to protect how can you
if you know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
president trump's view that the rioters
were not doing anything wrong
and that quote mike deserved it
helps us to understand why the president
did not ask the rioters to leave the
capitol for multiple hours right in fact
he put this tweet out at 2 24 p.m
miss hatch guys he wanted armed people
at the capitol he believed pence should
be hanged of course he didn't call them
off
i do
miss hutchinson what was your reaction
when you saw this tweet
as a staffer that worked
to always represent the administration
to the best of my ability
and to showcase the good things that he
had done for the country
i remember feeling
frustrated
disappointed
and
really it felt personal i was really sad
as an american
i was disgusted
[Music]
it was
unpatriotic it was
un-american we were watching the capitol
building get defaced over a lie
and it was something that was really
hard
in that moment to digest knowing what
i'd been hearing down the hall
and the conversations that were
happening
seeing that tweet come up and
knowing what was happening on the hill
and it's something that i
it's still i still struggled to work
through
the emotions of that
mr such as we have also spoken to
multiple other white house staff about
their reaction to donald trump's 224
tweet
condemning mike pence for not having the
courage
to refuse to count electoral votes an
act that would have been illegal
matthew pottinger a former marine
intelligence officer who served in the
white house for four years including
including as deputy national security
adviser was in the vicinity of the oval
office at various points throughout the
day
when he saw that tweet he immediately
decided to resign his position
let's watch him describe his reaction to
the president's tweet
one of my staff brought me a printout
of a
tweet
by the president
and the tweet uh said something to the
effect that uh mike pence the vice
president didn't have the courage
um uh to to do what he what should have
been done i remember that um i
i read that tweet
uh and uh made a decision
at that moment to resign
uh that's where i knew that i was
leaving that day uh once i read that
tweet wow
ultimately
members of the white house staff sarah
matthews cabinet members secretary chao
and secretary devos resigned as well
here is secretary devos's resignation
letter
as you can see in resigning on january 6
secretary devos said to the president
quote there's no mistaking the impact
your rhetoric had on the situation and
it is the inflection point for me
let's also look at secretary i can't
think that highly of these people who
resign i mean yes this was a crazy last
straw but you worked for trump for years
he was a lunatic the entire time
as i am sure is the case with many of
you
this has deeply troubled me in a way i
simply cannot set aside
miss hutchinson in our prior interviews
we've asked you about what the
president's advisors were urging him to
do during the attack
you've described roughly three different
camps of thought inside the white house
that day can you tell us about those
there's a group of individuals that were
strongly urging him to take immediate
and swift action
i would classify the white house
counsel's office mr hirschman miss
ivanka trump
in that category of
really working
to get him to take action and pleading
with him to take action
there was a more neutral group
where
advisors were trying to toe the line
knowing that mr trump didn't necessarily
want to take immediate action
and condemn the riots
but knowing something needed to be done
and then there was the last group which
was
deflect and blame
let's blame antifa these aren't our
people
it's my understanding that
mr meadows was in
the deflect and blame category but he
did end up taking a more neutral route
knowing that there were several advisers
in
the president's circle urging him to
take
more action
which i think was reflected in the
rhetoric released later that day in the
videos
you told us that the white house
counsel's office was in the camp
encouraging the president
to tell the writers to stop the attack
and to leave the capitol let's listen
white house counsel's office wanted
there to be a strong statement out to
condemn the rioters i'm confident in
that
now let's look at just one example of
what some senior advisors to the
president were urging
ms hutchinson could you look at the
exhibit that we're showing on the screen
now
have you seen this note before
that's a note that i wrote at the
direction of the chief of staff on
january 6 likely around three o'clock
and it's written on the chief of staff
note card but that's your handwriting ms
hutchinson that's my handwriting
and why did you write this note
the chief of staff was in a meeting with
eric hirschman and potentially mr
philbin and they had
rushed out of the office fairly quickly
mark had handed me the note card with
one of his pens
and started dictating a statement for
the president to potentially put out
and
no i'm sorry go ahead that's okay uh
there are two phrases on there one
illegal and then one without proper
authority
the illegal phrase was the one that mr
meadows had dictated to me
mr hershman had chimed in
and said also put without legal
authority
there should have been a slash between
the two phrases it was an or if the
president had opted to put one of those
statements out
evidently he didn't later that afternoon
mark came back from the oval dining room
and put the palm card on my desk
with illegally crossed out
but said we didn't need to take further
action on that statement
so
to your knowledge this statement was
never issued it was to my knowledge it
was never issued
and ms hutchinson did you understand
that ivanka trump
wanted her father to send people home
that's my understanding yes let's play a
clip of you addressing that issue
i remember her saying
at various points you know
she wants
him she wanted her dad to send them home
she wanted her dad to
tell them to go home peace and she
wanted to include
language that he necessarily wasn't on
board with at the time
you will hear more about this at our
later hearings but we have evidence of
many others
imploring donald trump and mark meadows
to take action
here is some of that evidence text
messages sent to mark meadows during the
attack
this is a text message at 232 from laura
ingram
hey mark the president needs to tell
people in the capitol to go home
in the next message this is hurting all
of us
and then he's destroying his legacy and
playing into every stereotype we lose
all credibility against the blm antifa
crowd if things go south right
the president's son don jr also urgently
contacted mark meadows
at 253 he wrote he's got to condemn this
[ __ ] asap the capital police tweet is
not enough right as you will see these
are just two of the numerous examples of
trump supporters and allies urging the
president to tell his supporters to
leave the capitol
it would not have been hard for the
president to simply walk down to the
briefing room
a few feet down the hall from the oval
office
as norah o'donnell noted during an
interview with house republican leader
kevin mccarthy
where leader mccarthy said he believed
the attack was un-american
i want to quickly bring in kevin
mccarthy the house minority leader
leader mccarthy
do you condemn this violence
i completely condemn the violence in the
capitol what we're currently watching
unfold is un-american
i am i'm disappointed i'm sad this is
not what our country should look like
this is not who we are this is not the
first amendment this has to stop and
this has to stop now
leader mccarthy the president united
states has a briefing room steps from
the oval office it is the cameras are
hot 24 7 as you know why hasn't he
walked down and said that now
[Applause]
i i convey to the president what i think
is best to do and i'm hopeful the
president will do it
republican house member mike gallagher
also
implored the president to call off the
attack
mr president
you have got to stop this you are the
only person who can call this
off
call it off
the election is over
call it off
this is bigger than you it's bigger than
any member of congress is about the
united states of america
which is more important than any
politician
call it off not the trump it's over
[Music]
despite the fact that many people close
to donald trump were urging him to send
people home he did not do so until later
much later
at 4 17 p.m donald trump finally told
the rioters to go home but we love them
and that he loved them
here's a portion of the video president
trump recorded from the white house
we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil
i know how you feel
but go home and go home at peace
but as we will show in even greater
detail in future hearings donald trump
was reluctant to put this message out
and he still could not bring himself to
condemn the attack
ms hutchinson has told us that too
um
i'm sure you've discussed it just to
elaborate if i hadn't already at that
point
i recall him
being reluctant to film the video on the
six i was not involved in
any of the logistics or the planning for
that video i just remember seeing the
video go out
and feeling a little shocked after it
went out
on the evening of january 6th and the
day after the president's family and his
senior staff and others
tried to encourage the president to
condemn the violence and commit to the
peaceful transition of power
at 3 31 p.m on january 6th sean hannity
of fox news texted mark meadows
mr hannity said quote can he make a
statement i saw the tweet
ask people to leave the capitol
later that evening mr hannity sent
another text message to mark meadows
this time he shared a link to a tweet
that tweet reported that president
trump's cabinet secretaries were
considering invoking the 25th amendment
to remove president trump from office
as you can see on the screen
the 25th amendment to the constitution
creates a process for the transition of
power if a president is unfit or unable
to serve
25th amendment has never been used to
remove a president
but the committee has learned that after
the attack on the u.s capitol this was
being discussed by members of president
trump's cabinet wow as a way of
stripping the full power of the
presidency from donald trump should have
been
president trump's supporters were
worried
in addition to the tweet that he sent
mark meadows after the attack
sean hannity apparently spoke with
president trump
and warned him about what could happen
we understand that this text message
that sean hannity sent to kaylee mcanany
on january 7th shows what mr hannity
said to the president first
no more stolen election talk
second
impeachment and 25th amendment are real
many people will quit
miss hutchinson you told us that you
were hearing about discussions related
to the 25th amendment here's part of
what you said
mr pompeo reached out to have the
conversation with mr meadows in case he
hadn't heard the
discussions amongst cabinet secretaries
and what i understand it was more of a
[Music]
this is what i'm hearing
i want you to be aware of it but i also
think it's worth putting on your radar
because you are the chief of staff
you're technically the boss of all the
cabinet secretaries and
you know if
conversations progress you should
be ready to take action on this like i'm
concerned for
you and your positioning with this yeah
please ask me if you have any questions
or like i could be helpful with you at
all
inside the white house the president's
advisers including members of his family
wanted him to deliver a speech to the
country
deputy white house counsel pat philbin
prepared the first draft of what would
be the president's remarks on national
healing
delivered by a pre-taped video on
january 7th
when he arrived at the white house on
the 7th mr philbin believed that more
needed to be said
so he sat down and started writing
he shared the draft with pat sipoloni
who also believed the president needed
to say more
mr sipoloni agreed with the content as
did eric hershman who reviewed the draft
the committee has learned that the
president did not agree with the
substance as drafted and resisted giving
a speech at all right miss hutchinson do
you recall discussions about the
president's speech on january 7th
i do
let's listen miss hutcheson to what you
told us about that and about the process
of crafting those remarks
uh i learned from a conversation with
mark and
over here and between him and white
house counsel and
eric hershman as well that
trump didn't necessarily think he needed
to do
anything more on the seventh than what
he had
already done on the six
when he was
convinced to put out a video on the
seventh
he i understand that he had
a lot of opinions about what the context
of that announcement were to entail um i
had original drafts of the speech where
you know there were several lines that
didn't make it in there about
prosecuting the rioters or calling them
violent
he didn't want that in there he wanted
to put him there that he wanted to
potentially pardon them
um it was just with the increased
emphasis of
his mindset at the time which was
he didn't think that they did anything
wrong he
the people who did something wrong that
day or the person who did something
wrong that day was mike pence by not
standing with him
but the president's advisers urged him
to give the speech
who convinced him to do
the video on the seventh i'm not sure
who convinced them if it was a group of
people that convinced him
who is in the group that you're aware of
that i'm aware of
mark ivanka
jared kushner
um
eric hershman pasaboloni
pat philbin
those are people that i'm aware of
do you know why that group of people
thought it was necessary for him to
release a statement
i believe kelly mcinerney as well
um
from what i understood at the time
and from what the reports were coming in
there's a
large concern of
the 25th amendment potentially being
invoked and
there were concerns about what would
happen in the senate
if it was if the 25th was invoked
so the primary reason that i had heard
other than you know
we did not do enough on the six we need
to get a stronger message out there and
condemn this otherwise this will be your
legacy the secondary reason to that was
think about what might happen in the
final 15 days of your presidency if we
don't
do this there's already talks about
invoking the 25th amendment you need
this as cover
the president ultimately delivered the
remarks
unlike many of his other speeches he did
not ad-lib much he recited them without
significant alteration except one
even then
on january 7th 2021
the day after the attack on the u.s
capitol the president still could not
bring himself to say quote but this
election is now over
one other point about the speech ms
hutchinson did you hear that mr trump at
one point wanted to add language about
pardoning those who took part in the
january 6 riot
i did hear that and i understand that mr
met that mr meadows was encouraging that
language as well oh my god
thank you and here's what you told us
previously about that
you said he was instructed not to
include it who was instructing him not
to include language about the pardon in
that january 7th i understood from white
house counsel's office coming into our
office that morning that they didn't
think that it was a good idea to include
that in the speech that being at
patented that's correct
and eric hershman
ms hutchinson
did rudy giuliani ever suggest that he
was interested in receiving a
presidential pardon related to january
6th
he did
ms hutchinson
did white house chief of staff mark
meadows ever indicate that he was
interested in receiving a presidential
pardon related to january 6th
mr meadows did seek that pardon yes
ma'am
thank you miss hutchinson mr chairman i
yield back
i want to thank our witness for joining
us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
witness
and we ask that you respond
expeditiously in writing to those
questions
without objections members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for the witness
without objection the chair recognized
the vice chair for a closing statement
wow thank you very much mr chairman
i want to begin by thanking ms
hutchinson for her testimony today we
are all in her debt
our nation is preserved by those who
abide by their oaths to our constitution
our nation is preserved by those who
know the fundamental difference between
right and wrong
and i want all americans to know that
what ms hutchinson has done today is not
easy
the easy course is trump's already
attacking her
to refuse to come forward to attempt to
downplay or deny what happened
that brings me to a different topic
while our committee has seen many
witnesses
including many republicans
testify fully and forthrightly
this has not been true of every witness
and we have received evidence
of one particular practice that raises
significant concern
our committee commonly asks witnesses
connected to mr trump's administration
or campaign
whether they've been contacted by any of
their former colleagues or anyone else
who attempted to influence or impact
their testimony oh boy without
identifying any of the individuals
involved let me show you a couple of
samples of answers we received to this
question
first
here's how one witness described phone
calls from people interested in that
witness's testimony
quote what they said to me is as long as
i continue to be a team player
they know i'm on the right team i'm
doing the right thing
i'm protecting who i need to protect
you know i'll continue to stay in good
graces in trump world
and they have reminded me a couple of
times
that trump does read transcripts and
just keep that in mind
as i proceed through my interviews with
the committee witness tampering
here's another sample in a different
context this is a call received by one
of our witnesses
quote a person let me know you have your
deposition tomorrow
he wants me to let you know he's
thinking about you uh-oh he knows you're
loyal
and you're going to do the right thing
when you go in for your deposition mob
tactics
i think most americans know that
attempting to influence witnesses to
testify untruthfully
presents very serious concerns
we will be discussing these issues as a
committee
carefully considering our next steps
mr chairman thank you i yield back
general woman yields back
ms hutchinson
thank you hutchins thank you for doing
your patriotic duty and helping the
american people
get a complete understanding of january
6 and its causes
thank you for your courage in testifying
here today
you have the gratitude of this committee
and your country i know it wasn't easy
to sit here today
and answer these questions
but after hearing your testimony in
all this candor in detail
i want to speak directly to the handful
of witnesses who have been outliers in
our investigation
the small number who have defied us
outright
those whose memories have failed them
again
and again
on the most important details
and to those who fear donald trump
and his enablers
because of this courageous woman and
others like her
you attempt to hide the truth from the
american people will fail
and to that group of witnesses
if you've heard this testimony today
and suddenly you remember things you
couldn't previously recall
are there some details you'd like to
clarify
or you discovered some
courage you had hidden away somewhere
our doors remain open
the select committee will reconvene in
the weeks ahead
as we continue to lay out our findings
to the american people
the chair requests those in the hearing
room to remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
the witness and members from the room
without objection
the committed stands are joined
by far
did not under promise when they said
this is intense stuff
the major allegations trump knew the
protesters had weapons and he wanted
them there and he wanted them at the
speech and he wanted them at the capitol
trump attacked a secret service agent
when the secret service refused to take
him to the capitol trump attempted to
take control of the vehicle being driven
by secret service
um
trump smeared ketchup on the wall in a
tirade when he wasn't getting what he
wanted
everything short of uh trump filled his
diaper i mean quite frankly
extraordinary extraordinary day of
testimony and trump is already going
absolutely insane
on truth social he just can't take it
truth essential we will look at all of
that tomorrow
as cassidy hutchinson
also referred to as cassie and also
referred to as hutchins
number of people struggling with her
name
uh finished her presentation
wow
all right folks make sure you're
subscribed free on youtube
make sure you're following on twitch
we will be back at the time of the next
hearing thank you for joining me
and we will see you very soon